Speaker 1: Our correspondent and occasional
guest host Luke Beasley, whose YouTube channel
you can find it David Pakman dot com slash
Luke was on the ground at the very, very disturbing
Trump rally in Waco, Texas over the weekend.
Luke spoke to a number of people.
The topics were wide ranging.
They included gay marriage, they included
crisis actors at sandy hook.
Yeah, it is 2023.
Don't adjust your TV screen.
It included philosophical questions about
how do we really know anything?
And it also included, of course, George Soros.
Let's start with the topic of gay marriage.
Here is Luke inquiring to a gentleman, and
I'm using that term loosely about gay marriage.
Let's listen.
Speaker 3: So what's inherently immoral about
gay marriage?
It is anti-life.
It is anti vital anti-life.
It does not produce kids.
And the marriage, it's Do you think it should
be legal for two straight people who decide
not to have kids married?
No.
I believe they should still get married.
But then that's anti life, right?
It is not anti life.
And I agree with you.
But then I reproduce reproducing, just like
to gay people don't reproduce.
Paul, I get what you're saying.
Basically, you talking about people who know
they're infertile and yet they want to get
married after saying any example that one,
two, you're saying ban infertile people from
getting married, even straight couples like,
you know, because at the end of the day, they
can still adopt kids and raise them.
Gay people can adopt kids, Right?
I don't believe they should.
There's no recent reports about a gay couple.
Speaker 1: This is what you call just ping
pong from one topic to another.
Gay people shouldn't get married because they
can't produce kids.
Neither can infertile couples.
And also some couples don't want to have kids.
Well, but they should be able to get married
because they can adopt.
But gay people can also add up.
Well, but gay people shouldn't be allowed
to adopt.
This is you.
You really can't.
Good for Luke, but you really can't talk to
these folks.
Speaker 3: All that is known to abuse their
kids.
Look up the stats.
I do.
I can find out about 13 gazillion examples
of straight couples abusing their kids.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So then he goes to the child abuse meme.
This is what it was.
This.
It's every.
Where this stuff is everywhere at these rallies,
it doesn't make any sense.
Here is a guy who's wearing an Alex Jones
was right t shirt who repeats a lot of the
Sandy Hook conspiracy is from more than a
decade ago that even Alex Jones has since
recanted.
Although you could argue Alex Jones recanted
only for legal reasons.
But okay, let's take a listen to this one.
Speaker 3: People saying you don't think Sandy
Hook parents were actually being harassed
and they had to move on, which you can see
they actually had to do that.
Pardon me?
These parents are just lying.
I mean.
Speaker 2: I think it you I think they're
lying.
Speaker 1: The question is, are the are the
Sandy Hook parents lying that they were being
harassed?
Speaker 2: I really.
I really want to answer that question.
Speaker 1: By the way, just so everybody knows,
this guy is a Christian, okay?
Oh, no.
Speaker 2: I don't know if they're lying.
You know, all of this.
Speaker 3: My my point is my my point is when
I see a parent crying because their kid got
murdered in a mass shooting.
My first instinct is to trust them and not
the guy who makes money lying about them.
Speaker 2: What about?
What about.
I mean, I do believe that the people that
was what they were, I guess they call them
some some crisis actors.
I mean, how do you explain that?
The crisis actors that they are.
Speaker 3: That's why you.
Speaker 1: See, this is a very interesting
moment.
How do you explain that there were crisis
actors?
What are you talking about?
That's not you're assuming something that
you haven't actually demonstrated.
Speaker 2: On the record in certain different
places.
I mean, you were in the same place.
Explain.
How do you deal with that government?
Speaker 3: I don't trust the government about
I trust the facts.
Speaker 2: Okay.
What are the facts?
Speaker 3: The facts are that.
Parents lost their children.
And then a man by the name of Alex Jones lied
about that and said there was crisis doctors
in the Ukraine with which nonsense.
Speaker 2: But people to get or something
because you know what I believe?
I believe the only reason that they're doing
this is because they're going to they've got
to take him down.
Speaker 1: Right.
It's all a conspiracy to take Alex Jones down
over things Alex Jones chose to say has since
recanted and which we know not to be true.
Well, it seems like a pretty big unforced
error.
Then we went to a woman who was very confused,
visibly confused, I would even say, about
why Trump would be arrested.
This is pretty interesting because it gets
very philosophical.
How do we know anything?
How can anything be proven in a court of law?
Speaker 4: I don't even know Alan.
Right.
Who's Alan bragging.
Speaker 3: With Alan about?
He's the Manhattan district attorney, and
he seems to be reportedly considering arresting
Trump.
Speaker 4: On what charges.
Speaker 3: In regard to the Stormy Daniels
hush money payment.
Speaker 4: I think this is what he did.
So how can they prove that that was actually
occurred?
See, that's the whole thing.
Or comes down to how do we know what is true.
Speaker 1: What is real.
Speaker 4: And that's where everything in
this stadium comes down to a spiritual reality.
Speaker 1: So her view is it's impossible
to ascertain truth at all.
So all we can do is find a religion to follow,
which simply tells us what is true.
Pretty convenient, I have to say.
If if it works for you, I can see why that
would be much more satisfying and pleasing
than understanding the chaos of the real world.
Speaker 4: The only way you can know what
is true is to believe that there's absolute
truth.
Do you believe the Bible is absolute truth?
You know, the reason America's having a problem
is because we need to get back to God.
Speaker 3: Just a quick question.
So if it's not like this evidence here, you
and I can look at, okay, is this something
that occurred?
How do we feel about that?
Instead, it's a spiritual decision to understand
truth.
Right.
And how do you and I come to some understanding
of one reality?
If my spiritual truth is.
Speaker 4: Good, who's evil?
I'm saying between good and evil.
Speaker 3: I'm saying it might feel like if
spiritually, I were to feel that Trump is
bad because of his anti-democratic views or
actions, he took his president and then used
fears of violence.
Good.
How would we come to some sort of agreement
or even understanding genocide if it's not
based on kind of empirical information?
Speaker 4: Well, that's a whole big you could
call it a hurricane of a conversation that
I would love to get into all the navies and
greenies of it.
Speaker 3: But probably not.
But we're.
Speaker 4: Going to run out time.
Speaker 1: Here.
All right.
Yeah.
So anyway, how do we know anything is really
the question?
And that's where religion comes in for this
woman.
But of course, it's like which religion?
You've got a thousand religions and they very
often conflict with each other.
Luke then spoke to the first guy to raise
the topic of George Soros and looks pretty
slick here in the questions he's asking, sort
of trying to get at the anti-Semitic undertones
of all of this.
The guy kind of dodges it a little.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Look away.
He's running the country.
Who?
Our borders are free to come and go.
BIDEN But more like more of his puppeteers.
Speaker 3: Which are who?
Speaker 2: SOROS George Soros, media in general.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: Why is it that you use that particular
term puppeteers in relation to Soros?
Speaker 2: Because he has enough money.
He can buy anybody here.
Speaker 3: He How much money has he given
to Joe Biden?
Speaker 2: I have no idea.
Speaker 1: And there it is.
Speaker 3: And, you know, is it controlling
him?
Speaker 2: Because that's what I read.
That's what I hear.
Speaker 3: And you think the election was
stolen.
Now who don't know?
Speaker 2: I mean, I believe that there are
people probably voted more often than they
should, you know, and I believe there's a
lot of people who were not registered that
did vote.
Speaker 1: How do you vote if you're not registered?
It's never clear.
Speaker 2: I think after.
Speaker 3: All those things.
Speaker 2: I don't have anything.
I mean, I have as much evidence as all the
other people here.
Speaker 1: In that particular crowd.
There is a noticeable lack of evidence.
I'm glad the guy is identifying That is not.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Okay, so then don't you feel it's pretty dangerous
to say the election stolen if you don't have
evidence?
I didn't say no.
No, you didn't.
You're right.
I'm saying sorry.
I'm into sports about Trump because he says.
Speaker 2: Well, before you start, when you're
got that much money and stuff, you can sweep
a lot of things under the rug until the rugs
to fall.
Right?
And that starts.
Speaker 3: But if you don't have evidence,
I could say anything about anything.
You're murder.
I don't have an evidence.
But you can sweep down the road, you know?
I mean.
Yeah, that's.
Speaker 2: Right.
And when you're a politician, you're just
sitting there as a target for anybody who
wants to accuse you of anything.
Speaker 3: Well, I'm confused if.
Well, maybe that's the question I had is.
Speaker 1: This is if you're confused by what
this guy saying, that's the right reaction.
Speaker 3: Do you think it's dangerous for
people's belief in the legitimacy of our democracy
to say it was stolen?
It doesn't work anymore without solid evidence.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: He agrees it's extremely dangerous
what he's doing.
Speaker 3: So then for me, I would have a
really hard time, even if I like other policy
supporting political leader, if the most important
part of our political process, our democratic
institutions and process is being kind of
assaulted by his rhetoric.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think he talks too much.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So anyway, yeah, Trump probably should be
saying that the guy says, same guy here with
another woman.
I think this might be his wife, but I don't
know.
Apparently, his wife doesn't believe January
6th is really a big deal.
That should even really be talked about very
much.
Speaker 2: To help you see Trump rallies where
they start turning cars over and burning them.
Speaker 3: January 6th.
Speaker 1: Well, no.
Speaker 2: They didn't.
Speaker 4: Do that.
Speaker 2: Oh, my God, man.
Yeah.
Speaker 4: I don't say no.
We don't get killed there.
Speaker 3: We just talk about we're not fighting.
Speaker 4: To disagree that we believe.
Speaker 3: What do we talk about?
January six?
It's all I'm saying, that.
Speaker 1: It's just a media story.
It's not even real.
Speaker 2: Years ago.
Yeah.
Why do they keep bringing it up and rehashing
in different way?
Speaker 3: I can tell you, because it was
an attempt to subvert the will of the people
and block the certification of a president.
Got elected.
No.
Speaker 1: No.
See the guys?
It's that simple.
Why bother learning about things?
Just do what this woman says.
You just say no.
Well, it was an attempt to subvert the will
of the people and install a president who
didn't actually win.
No.
Wow.
That's a pretty good argument, ma'am, I have
to say.
And then last clip here.
Here's a woman who believes Trump won, but
she's very confused.
Speaker 3: What makes you believe Trump won?
Speaker 5: Because he has the majority of
people.
Speaker 3: Even though the official vote counts.
Don't show that.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Now, did you notice that she says,
look around here.
There are 3500 people here in Waco, Texas,
who support Trump.
Clearly, that proves that a country of 330
million voted for him.
Speaker 5: It was a fraud.
What people did, they.
They deceived.
Speaker 3: What you're saying looking around
here helps you see that the majority with
Trump.
Speaker 5: Definitely.
So we love President Trump.
The American people love America.
Speaker 3: Here's kind of an analogy.
Do you know who Taylor Swift is?
Yes, the pop artist.
So I've gone.
She's she's great.
I've gone to one of her concerts before.
And it's this a massive stadium, probably
three or four times the amount of people who
will be at this event there to see Taylor
Swift.
And so there it would seem like everyone knows
and loves Taylor Swift.
But we understand if you polled Americans,
it probably won't be a majority who are fans
of Taylor Swift.
And so that kind of gives you a sense of when
you're within a bubble, it can seem good,
everyone.
Speaker 1: Good for Luke.
He's trying, but it's not getting through.
Speaker 3: Loves a particular thing or is
a fan of a particular person when in reality
the broader world doesn't actually match that.
And so we have to look at things like data,
empirical information such as our election
results to understand what the actual majority,
once.
Speaker 5: He won fair and square.
Speaker 1: Got.
I mean, that's pretty convincing, right?
Speaker 4: He got the majority.
Speaker 5: He we love.
Speaker 1: He didn't even get the majority
of the popular vote.
Speaker 5: Him is the American people.
He has stood for Israel.
He has stood for the unborn.
He doesn't drink.
Right.
He has good morals.
He has good kids.
He has good grand kids.
Speaker 4: And we are blessed to have him
as the.
Speaker 3: President of the United States.
There you go.
Shibley.
Speaker 1: Hard to hard to argue against folks
who don't actually care about reality, but
they care about I don't know.
It looks like people here like him.
That seems pretty good to me.
Really nice job by Luke and and a range of
topics, a range of people.
Really good stuff.
And we'll have all of these clips if you're
just listening to that.
You want to see what the whole scene is like
visually.
And I do recommend that we'll have these clips
up on our YouTube channel, YouTube.com slash
The David Pakman Show, and we'll also have
them on our Instagram and on TikTok.
These clips are going to be everywhere, believe
me.